my parents watch my show and sometimes
I'm doing stuff we're talking about
stuff and I I think what are they going
to think about this do you have that
situation yeah well my parents are like
really really cool like I grew up in San
Francisco with like hip parents my mom's
all tatted up and my dad your mom is
tatted up oh yeah oh cool all right
tattoos and fingerless gloves and she's
very cool and she's a poet and a
novelist and my dad's a Buddhist priest
but was like a street theatre artist
anyway so like okay you just toss that
off like you know the deal mom's taught
it up with fingerless gloves dad's a
Buddhist priest we all know how that
goes they're just not very conservative
when I was um when I was in high school
I came home and there was a penthouse on
our coffee table and I was like why is
there a penthouse on our coffee table
and my mom opened it up and pointed to
an article and she had written an erotic
short story and she was like you got to
pay the bills baby I'm paying the bills
with but stuff yeah a nice what goes
around comes around
so you're told you so your mom wrote did
she write a lot of erotic fiction or was
that just the one thing she she has a
book of erotic short stories which I
have not read that's sort of the weird
to read your mom's erotic fiction I
think yeah I read everything else she's
an amazing her name is came out of need
Co she'd kill me if I didn't say her
name go buy her books but yeah but she
writes a lot and that's the only thing
that I don't I don't read to my husband
at night when she when she when you were
a kid growing up is it at all
intimidating to have a mom who's that
cool oh of course
I mean they've always been much cooler
than me and my mom my mom would come to
my middle school to pick me up in like a
hot little leopard print number and all
the boys would be into her and I was a
little flat-chested girl and it was my
life was so hard yeah
I sympathize I was once a little
flat-chested girl easier to talk to mom
about sex then I'm guessing if she's
that cool is it is it you know that's
what I always would think is that if
your mom's like that would mean talking
to her would be very easy yeah she was
very cool she when I was a teenager the
birds and the bees talk was very much
you know whatever you do be safe and you
know come to me when you are ready and
so I came to her when I was ready and
she said absolutely not you're way too
young so you know she's still mom even
if she's a cool mom mom said that's me
when I was 35 wasn't that a great clip
subscribe to my youtube channel for an
endless supply of me
[Laughter]